hello um i'd just like to thank lab
roots for the opportunity to speak
my name is bridget algie hewitt i'm a
senior research scientist
at stanford university in the center for
comparative studies and race
and ethnicity i'm a biological
anthropologist by training with
specialization in forensic anthropology
and my area of focus is in computational
methods
or improving human identification
specifically
along the u.s mexico border and that's
what i will be speaking about today
my talk forensic anthropology at the
line
or the colloquial term
for the border advances in computational
methods for the identification of the
u.s
mexico border dead
the recovery laboratory analysis and
return of human remains
of unknown identity is important in
humanitarian context
and i would argue one if not the most
pressing areas of need
and challenging areas of research for
forensic anthropology today
is the u.s mexico border
violence unrest poverty and persecution
have forced thousands of latin american
migrants from their home countries
to attempt the perilous journey el norte
through the deserts
the jungles the urban spaces of central
america and mexico
some perish from dehydration exhaustion
and injury
others crumble under the weight of
deterrence policies that shape the
landscape of the u.s mexico borderlands
in the last 20 years alone over 7 500
migrants have been found deceased
after attempting to cross the u.s mexico
border over 5 500 migrants have been
reported disappeared
countless more missing and deceased and
many remains will never be found
enforcement only policies like operation
gate
gatekeeper already 25 years old or the
present day migrant protection protocols
which many of us
know as the remain in mexico policy
represent
strategies of control through deterrence
these acts of control
are successful but successful at
increasing risk of death
the control policies also work to
humanize dehumanize
migrants and as deterrent actions they
not only increase the risk of death but
also the magnitude of actual death
counts the resulting counts then are a
reminder of the humanitarian
crisis and the human consequences
of the militarization of the borderlands
and the criminalization of the
undocumented
just as the undocumented or forced by
structural
institutional and physical violence into
the shadowed margins of society
in life they are left to remain faceless
nameless and disappeared even in death
so as a reminder then in the last 20
years alone
7 500 migrants have been found deceased
when attempting to cross the border 5500
or more
have been reported disappeared countless
more missing and deceased
and many remains will never be found
perspectives can be i think better
grasped by a
more focused approach to the analysis
so we're going to look at today
estimates from pima county in arizona
and that encompasses the tucson area
conservative estimates from pima county
alone suggests that
over 3 000 migrants died while
attempting to cross the border
since 2000 1200
or so remain unidentified and the pima
county office of the medical examiner
um is one of the largest forensic
anthropology
case analysis centers for the border
so one of the problems with the border
identification
is the changing trends in death and
identification success
and in a period when border crossing
counts were
or are historically low at the end of
the obama presidency they had actually
reached an
unprecedented level of
reduction migrants are now perishing
at ever-increasing numbers at the same
time
the ability of the forensic
anthropologists to positively identify
the migrant dead
is declining at an unprecedented rate
yet we're finding that our case
protocols are
not changing
pima county office of the medical
examiner has reported
a decrease in positive identification
rates of migrant deaths
from 75 percent in 2003
to 45 in 2013.
it's remarkable to see such a change in
only a decade and it should give us as
scientists
and advocates and practitioners
great pause and motivation
for improving identification rates and
actually getting at the source of this
issue
so in the throes of this crisis
immediate improvement to forensic
identification is critical
as we have to attempt to speak the story
of the dead
as our role as forensic anthropologists
give closure to the family and friends
of the missing
and uphold our values of social justice
and commitment to human rights
improvement i would argue though cannot
be achieved by the traditional methods
forensic anthropology alone
these are the methods that have brought
about that reduction in
positive identification rates and we are
faced with a new border culture
a new border environment given different
policies and different peoples
crossing the border so these new
conditions demand equally new
and especially holistic approaches to
casework id
that take all of not only the individual
but the context and the social
conditions
into account
and this is i think most important
um in light of the fact that migrants do
not just disappear
they are disappeared so taking into
account that
holism of the migrant the missing
migrant issue
is critical because there are several
scientific and societal factors that
actively impede the successful recovery
identification
and repatriation of missing migrants
along the border and there's numerous
they depend on the methods that we use
the reference collections that are used
to facilitate these methods the problem
of dna degradation
because we're working in the desert so
that's going to be a
issue of dna preservation
post-mortem interval will also um in the
desert
rapidly decompose remains which changes
your
opportunity for making identifications
using particular methods
the recovery context is critical and i'm
going to talk about that later
where the location along the border
makes a difference in our ability to
actually infer information about the
individual
preservation again dna and
soft tissue preservation etc is all
going to be affected by
environment it's essential to note
that while profiles may be uploaded to
codis
border crossers are very rarely
criminals
and they're very rarely than in criminal
databases
they are mothers fathers sisters
brothers families coming with
children they're not going to be
identified then
by using the traditional forensic means
that said then we have poor comparative
databases we don't have a
comprehensive migrant database
for families to report they're missing
and include their dna in
or for forensic anthropologists to
include the dna from those who have not
yet been
identified we have shifting
migrant demographics which means that
methods and protocols that were
established under the assumption
that all migrants come from northern
mexico that may have been true
at one point in time are radically
outdated
by the shifts in the demographic makeup
of who's actually
migrating now and crossing and dying on
the border
also issues of infrastructure who is
going to support
this kind of work the funding to pay for
the dna testing
the political policies that may prohibit
certain types of um activities or
inhibit those
um policies whether or not those are
political in terms of presidential
policies but they can be
policies of people working within
universities areas where
time is considered to be best well spent
there's also public opinions on methods
of identification
and what is a value
that can get transmitted to um
in the course of the expert giving their
um opinion and then it actually ending
up uh reported to someone else and
interpreted
and then it may impede an identification
that brings me to reporting access not
all families
have access to a reporting location
of opportunity to give a dna sample
this is because they have a
potential lack of knowledge of the
presence of forensic anthropologists
there's um obviously a disconnect
between
people who are migrating from mexico
central america and they're being
expected
unreasonably to have some knowledge that
forensic anthropologists are present and
able to aid
in the united states in addition to that
there is fear and problems of
trust with governmental and
institutional agencies
many of the people who are migrating
come from structurally vulnerable groups
they are marginalized oppressed and
fearful
so to reach out to a agency that they
feel
is akin to a oppressive structure
would be um would be very problematic
and then there's just simple issues of
communication
so not all forensic anthropologists
speak spanish
have the ability to communicate in that
way
and then more pressingly not all
migrants
speak standard spanish so even if there
is that level of communication
and there's someone whose boots on the
ground who they can actually connect
with
they may not be able to communicate
and then there is a larger issue of
education how do we
disseminate our knowledge and our
ability to aid
in the places that need them to
populations
that are already fearful of that kind of
interaction
so there are many social and scientific
issues that we need to address
in tandem and many of these
impediments are directly related to the
systems of structural vulnerability
and the presence of institution and
physical violence that compel
these forced migrants to take up this
journey such factors will include
poverty
mistrust of government fear of law
enforcement gang brutality political
violence and ethnic persecution
so then in light of that list of factors
the greatest barrier to positive
identification are the lack of family
reporting of the missing and the absence
of reference dna
for kin matching these impediments are
exacerbated by the often
limited availability of information on
the place of origin
or the sending region of the unknown
which can be critical for seeking out
family members and for submitting case
reports with dna profile results
sg migrants as i said are found in
criminal databases
so as i've already said marginalization
begets marginalization
through that concept that forced
migrants do not disappear but they are
forcibly disappeared
these structural factors prevent knowing
about the unknown
in the absence of family data accessing
information
on origins by other means is therefore
critical
so we have to figure out where to send
this information
or who to start asking to go ask
around for family members but we can't
do that if we don't know
the geographic location where this
unknown individual originated
so then how can we improve case
identification success
well motivated by these increasing
number of unsuc successful
identifications of missing migrants
how can we address this barrier to
improve rates of positive identification
and repatriation of the border debt so
my response to this question is to
engage try hybrid ancestry estimates
so the uh proportions of
ancestry for each individual the
case recovery location so the gps
coordinates where that individual was
recovered along the border
and because these the cases that i'm
working on to build these
this analysis or model is are already
positively identified
then i have their place of origin or
their sending region already
and i'm using these three sets of
variables to develop a
biogeographic profile which is a
model that allows me to predict sending
region
to aid in the skin matching and to
enable
repatriation
and how is this possible so
genetic diversity in latin america is
very high
studies using genetic and skeletal data
alike have revealed differences in
ancestry
for many of the geospatially defined
groups that are distributed across latin
america
so we can use this spatial organization
or structure
in ancestry estimates to reveal
information on their spending regions
we can also capitalize upon information
that we can get from those who are
successful
at crossing the border so we can
understand the habits of the living
to shed greater light on the context of
the dead
so demographic research and migration
networks have found distinctive
transit pathways whereby migrants of
different origins
so with different state or city of birth
or residents are associated with
particular destinations
so you come from a particular place you
are more likely to cross the border
at a particular location the pathways
through mexico and the crossing points
along the u.s mexico border are
shared by experience so if
you have family who have successfully
crossed or friends they transmit that
information back
to your hometown that information then
informs the next um persons who
attempt the journey so it's a
perpetualization of these
same transit pathways that are clearly
linked by
point of origin and point of destination
and we can use these trends then to
predict the sending region
for the missing migrants
how did i develop this procedure
so i started out with 150 cases from the
pima county office of the medical
examiner in arizona
i applied model-based clustering
geospatial
analysis machine learning and
traditional statistical methods
to produce this biogeographic profile
and i'll explain how i've done that in
more detail
as we move along to this goal then the
relationships among
ancestry composition so that trihybrid
ancestry
breakdown the geographic location of the
remains
so those gps coordinates on the border
the sending region of the place of
origin of the individual
their sex and their case reporting date
were all investigated
and i took that information then built
models that predict the individual's
documented sending region as a micro
regional category
on the one hand and then remarkably it's
even possible to predict the gis
coordinates for that sending region when
those coordinates are taken as the
centroid
of the area
state typically from which they
originated
so how do we
calculate craniometric measures of
ancestry
um so i'm sure you're familiar with
ancestry estimates being derived from
genetic data
here what i've done is i've rewritten
the mathematics for
the genetic which is categorical
trait analysis to a continuous trait
analysis
so that i produce very similar
results to the genetic data
using almost identical or highly
comparable
mathematical procedures how is this
possible through craniometrics
well measurements of the cranium or
craniometrics have been used as proxies
for genetic data
to study microevolutionary processes
trace patterns of variation
and reveal information on population
history and individual biology
all through anthropology for its history
and this is because craniometrics have
low plasticity with high to moderate
heritabilities
proportions of ancestry then can be
calculated from cranium metrics
using model based clustering
implemented with the methods of finite
mixture analysis
and what's exciting about this approach
is that it's an admixture approach
that's comparable to the methods that
are used in genetics so if you're
familiar with the software admixture or
structure
it's the same kind of philosophy and
it's preferable
i would argue to the traditional single
group hard classification methods that
are used
um ubiquitously in forensic anthropology
because they don't
allow us to get at the nuance of the
geography so by producing these
proportions
we can identify signatures that
represent
geographic regions these geographic
regions need not be
labeled in the same way as a
geopolitical region so we can actually
map them onto real geographic space
and see how they vary and then create
our own
partitions or organization to those that
make
sense based on the
relationships that we're seeing in the
ancestry estimates and in the gis
coordinates
so how is how are these ancestry
estimates actually produced
each individual's ancestry is reframed
as a mixture of parental contributors
and if it's tri-hybrid we presume that
latin american peoples are
have their ancestry made up by european
african and indigenous components
so we calculate the mixture of those
components for each individual
or we can think of them as the degree of
affinity
between groups as well so once you have
those three
components then you can look at how much
sharing
occurs between different populations
based on the similarity in their
ancestry signatures
and this differs fundamentally from a
single ancestry classification for
multiple reasons first that we start out
with the unknowns
individual and we have a reference
sample of individuals as well
but we strip all of those individuals
from
there we strip away from those
individuals their identifiers
so no sex no population no information
on them whatsoever
we just use their data we subject it to
the model based clustering and we get a
probabilistic
allocation so we can see how
individuals share between all of the
clusters
and each one of those clusters adds up
to one
so sorry of the combination of the
clusters add up to one
each one of the clusters contributes in
some proportion
of that one or one hundred percent
so individuals vary in each of those
um three ancestry proportions which then
serves as providing a signature
for the individual and then when
aggregated in terms of a population
or a region or however you want to
partition it you get a mean signature
that then allows you for tests of
differences etcetera
a single ancestry classification starts
out with
predefined groups so presumably
geographically defined populations for
which you have information
you have your unknown individual and
your unknown individual is allocated
into one of those groups even though
that individual may not
actually be a member of one of those
groups if their true membership is not
represented in the reference samples
similarly it doesn't address issues of
admixture
which um in current
modern times is a really gene admixture
is gene flow
so it's a it's an important factor to
build into our models
so what do i find then after i've done
this analysis where i've looked at the
correspondence between ancestry
proportions their place of
origin their place of recovery
and they these other factors of sex and
um and cashier well i found most
predominantly that ancestry is
structured by geography
geographic signatures are revealed in
the ancestry proportions as i had hoped
these patterns can be used to determine
than the likely sending region
so if we see in the um
in the map of mexico we can see that
there is a gradation
or a climb in the degree of european to
indigenous ancestry
and that plays out well when we actually
map these signatures in terms of the
different regions of mexico
so the southeastern part of mexico has
indeed individuals with the
with the signature whose largest
proportion is
um indigenous ancestry whereas
northern mexico the individuals have
their highest proportion of european
ancestry
and then we can map out how everyone in
between those
two points fall similarly we can
produce the same kind of analysis for
countries
other than mexico so we can look at this
is
um the second part you'll see a series
of countries
and the same tri-hybrid ancestry
proportions that create
a signature that represents guatemala or
a signature that represents
puerto rico and instead of then lumping
all cases as hispanic as is
a tendency in forensic anthropology we
are now
able to get at these individual
populational trends
that allow us to link population with
geography
i also found that the there are
significant spatial relationships
so if we map the cases um
by their region of origin and their
ancestry
along the border um their place of
recovery along the border
it's remarkable to see that the
regions in mexico cluster in particular
places along the border
as i had hoped as well so recall when i
mentioned that we can learn
about the patterns of the dead by
studying the
transit pathways and migration habits of
the living
this i think exemplifies that
a way of thinking so if you look at the
lower right hand corner map with the
big circles the circle in the center
represents all the migrants from
southern mexico
and then the circles to the right-hand
side
and left-hand side represent um
the traditional area of mexico
and northern mexico and then the central
area
um is falling as an overlap between
the south and the traditional area
so we can see that there are clear
patterns to
where the migrants are coming from and
where they're crossing
and then also we see that there are
patterns in their ancestry
in those um in the positions as well
and um this uh
spatial autocorrelation analysis is a
formal test for that
so it demonstrates that in their
ancestry patterns
there is more evidence of clustering
than
if there if it was just at random or by
chance
and i think these two plots um
are perhaps the most uh clear and um
the most relevant so we see that
individuals crossing
at the border are clustered
based on their degree of ancestry so
individuals with high indigenous
ancestry
tend to be in the central part of the
region
along the border whereas european are on
the periphery
and if you think back to that previous
slide with the circles
southern mexico was in the central
area of the border which of course
based on my other slide that showed that
gradation and ancestry
estimates um southern mexico and high
indigenous ancestry
should be the pattern that we would like
to see and that's what's actually played
out in the maps
so can we actually take this information
then and build this into a model
that can be used for prediction of that
geographic region in mexico
so i attempted first logistic regression
it explained only 38
of the variation and misclassified 43 of
the cases
significant improvement was achieved
with
machine learning methods so a neural
network using 12 nodes two hidden layers
activated by the hyperbolic tangent
function
with that type of model we got a really
high prediction accuracy
with even with leave one note cross
validation if we use a holdout sample
however
validation as validation um the r square
in prediction accuracy was only
slightly lower and still pretty
remarkable
what i think i find most exciting is the
use of discriminate function
analysis because it is well known among
anthropologists
and it's very simply implemented and it
doesn't have the same black boxing
qualities that say a neural network does
and i found that discriminate analysis
produced
really exciting results overall
misclassification is low
at less than 12 percent if we attempt to
classify
the individuals into their region of
mexico
and the best classification rate is for
the north
um and i will say that the
classification rate is best for the
north because
most likely because i had also more
northern samples
if once i balanced out the samples
north and south were quite equivalent
so what is the advantages of going
through this more
complex um approach to
um addressing ancestry and questions of
um biogeographic profile estimation
rather than just traditionally
estimating ancestry and providing that
within a case report
well using this biogeographic profile
approach
it's possible to identify the hot spots
where
we may expect to find remains and
mobilize workers to search those areas
and target areas where death occurs more
frequently
um and these would be on the pathways
that are now underserved or no longer
served by support systems
so there is a advantage for actually
recovering remains
it also provides valuable lines of
evidence to direct case investigations
or to support partial identifications if
our sending region
isn't known and family members from
migrant communities are not
reached are too fearful to report
they're missing
and cannot provide comparative dna
samples
the identification potential drops
significantly for the future
so we need a way that if we don't have
family members
coming to us to report or going having
the opportunity to
go some to someone an ngo a humanitarian
aid group in their
location to report a missing family
member
how can we transmit that information
back
we need to know where to send it to
the method that i've developed here at
least
provides us with the first step towards
accessing that
origin information or sending region for
the individual
using relatively little information
that wouldn't already be collected in a
traditional forensic anthropological
case analysis gps coordinates
are obtained craniometric measurements
are taken routinely as part of the
standard ancestry estimate
we always know when the case was
recovered
and we have information on sex and time
should those two variables actually
prove to be
more informative i should go back and
say that
those variables didn't add much to the
model so it was simpler to remove them
without without complicating the model
so i think we have great potential for
um
thinking outside of the traditional
methods but that
bring in aspects of those traditional
methods
the craniometrics gis mapping is not
unfamiliar to forensic anthropologists
and to just integrate them in a
different way that allows us to answer
some of the most pressing questions
that are creating the greatest
impediments to
positive identification
and with that i would just like to thank
dr bruce anderson
at pima county um bruce is i'm sure to
the forensic community well known
and has been a pioneer and a tireless
advocate for identifying missing
migrants
and rebecca vanderwaal who is the
student who i collaborated with on uci
uiuc
um and i'd like to thank um
labyrinths again for the opportunity to
speak with you today